رونالدو سجل ولا رونالدو ما سجل هذا
السؤال لكل الناس عم تساله كل الناس عم
تتداولوا الاستديوهات تحليليه مفتوحه التي
تناقش بالموضوع هل هي قولها لمستها
حسب رونالدو هاي كلها تفاصيل وامور يعني
شاغل الدنيا من امبارح من مباراه اوروجواي
اللي انتهت بهدفين مقابل لا شيء للمنتخب
البرتغالي وخزت له دور 16 لحد هاي اللحظه
الى عم منصور فيها بكل امانه رفع الكره
طبعا بالتجاه رونالدو وهذا الكلام اللي
قاله برونه لصحيفه اتلتيكو بعض المباراه
كان القصد انه يرفع الكره لا كريستيانو
رونالدو
ولكن الكره لمست لمست الفار قال ما لمست
ولكن رونالدو احتجاجه والطريقه اللي اعترض
فيها على احتساب القولون او خلينا نقول
استغرب احتساب القوه البرورو كانت بتبين
ان هو لمس الكره براسه وكان في وجهه نظر
بتقول انه طالما اللاعب قال انه لمسها
فاذا هي هدف للاعب اللي اعترف بلمس الكره
او اكد انه لمس الكره بالمقابل كان في
وجهه نظر ثاني بتقول
دائما التكنولوجيا والبار راح يعطيك
القرار الصح لانه عنده الادوات وعندهم طرق
الممكن اللي ممكن يحددوا فيها اذا كان
الهدف لمس اذا كانت الكره لمست
اول شيء خلينا نعرف اهميه الهدف اهميه هذا
الهدف انه كان راح يوصل رونالدو الهدف رقم
تسعه بكاس العالم يعني هو نفس عدد اهداف
الاسطوره البرتغاليه يوزيبيو في هذه
البطوله وبالتالي هو هدف مهم جدا
لكريستيانو رونالدو تاريخيا ليحطم رقم اخر
في جمله الارقام اللي حطمها عبر التاريخ
اضف الى ذلك انه كريستيانو رونالدو واحد
من اللعيبه اللي دائما بمنافسه مستمره مع
ليونيل ميسي على الارقام القياسيه في كاس
العالم وميسي طبعا سجل هدف امام
المكسيك بالمباراه الاخيره وبالتالي صارت
امور متقاربه جدا بين رونالدو لذلك
رونالدو رونالدو تحدثت انه يرفع عدد
اهدافه بالمونديال لحتى ياكد تفوق على
ميسي بالاضافه طبعا لا كسر رقم يزيديو
وطبعا احتفاله بالهدف ما كان ناجم عن انه
هو سجل لا احتفاله بالهدف كان نتيجه انه
هو الهدف اللي كسر همم الجليد في تلك
المباراه الصعبه امام منتخب الاوروجواي
بعد ما كانت المجيد نتيجه
اهل البرتغال الى دور 16 طيب السؤال الاخر
الان هل ممكن يرجع ينحسب الهدف لكريستيانو
رونالدو يعني هو بالاول حسبنا رونالدو
وبعدين الفيفا قرر انه هو اللي سجل الهدف
وتغيرت الصوره كامله وظهرت صوره البرون
وفرنانديز بملعب المباراه وانا حسب
الهدفنه وشفنا لقطه رونالدو وهو بيضحك لما
شاف انه حسب الهدفرونه طريفه بصراحه يعني
كانت مباراه امبارح وكل لاعبي الب قال
سؤلوا عن الموضوع بالمناسبه حتى المدرب
ولكن كل التفاق على انه مش مهم يسجل المهم
انه البرتغال فازت بالنهايه ومعظم
اللاعبين كانوا شايفين انه عندهم احساس
انه رونالدو لمس الكره حتى برونو كان عنده
هذا الاحساس الان السؤال هل يمكن ان يحسب
الهدف مره اخرى لرونالدو بالحقيقه نعم في
لجنه بتشكلها الفيفا بهذه
الظروف او بهذه الاحداث المعينه همم
بيدرسوا فيها مره اخرى الهدف هاي اللجنه
بتراجع الهدف بشكل دقيق جدا وبتتاكد هل
الكره لمست كريستيانو رونالدو ولا ما
لمسته واذا كانت لمست فبيغير قرار
وبيحسبوا الهدف رونالدو واذا ما لمستها
بيظل الهدف محسوب لبرونه فرنانديز لذلك
لعشاق كريستيانو رونالدو بعد في امل انه
الهدف حسب لكريستيانو وبعد في امل انه
كريستيانو يوصل لهدف التاسع بمباراه
الاوروغواي بكاس العالم 2022 وهو الهدف
الثاني له في هذه النسخه من
على كل حال مبروك لجمهور البرتغال التاهل
الى الدور الثاني وخلينا نشوف لمن سيحسب
الهدف لبرونو ولا رونالدو